[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMMA WATKINS: In high school,
I was really drawn to theater
because you could be
a very big person,
but you would be couched
behind a character.
But what I then
decided is that I
would take on the experience
of being a playwright,
and suddenly, the
experience reversed.
And I had the opportunity
to see my words,
but spoken by somebody else,
which was exhilarating.
But it's also
completely terrifying
because suddenly you're
vulnerable in a completely
new way.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I had taken a really
exceptional English class
with a professor who was
very interested in mythology
and feminism.
I explored Sondheim's
"Into the Woods"
and was looking at the
way fairy tales are
reimagined in that play.
It was an opportunity for me to
really see how a music theater
piece can explore
this older material,
and to innovate with it,
and introduce new themes.
So when I decided to
propose my thesis,
I began looking at
mythology that was closely
linked to my own family.
And so my father
is Welsh and was
really interested in telling me
little snippets of folk tales
as bedtime stories.
I found a female protagonist who
was really interesting to me.
So this was Rhiannon, and
she's a very outspoken
female character.
She read as incredibly
modern, and it
was surprising to find that
in a mythological tale.
I was really interested in
bringing forward her voice
from the mythology
in the same way
that Sondheim takes
the fairy tales
and create something of his own.
The really exciting thing
about the Lewis Center,
the entire theater
season is almost entirely
created around senior
thesis projects.
And so you get to work with so
many incredible collaborators.
And most of them are students.
So I had a student
director working
on the project, and a
student lighting designer,
and a wonderful team of
student musicians and actors.
And I had the opportunity
to travel to Wales to really
research and visit
the places where
the mythology takes place.
The idea of that was to bring
the folk music of Wales,
to bring the storytelling
tradition that's currently
alive in Wales into the
theater because we're
creating a show in a
black box in New Jersey.
But I wanted to make sure
that the story was rooted
in the place that it came from.
So next year, I have the
extraordinary opportunity
to continue studying
contemporary storytelling
performances and revivals
of mythology in Wales.
And so I'm hoping to
continue revising Rhiannon
and to create new work
based on mythology,
and looking at how
mythology can be
used to address contemporary
issues of feminism,
environmentalism.
And I think at so
many other schools,
you're working with
preexisting repertoire.
You as a thesis student, you
very much create something
and are given the opportunity
to run with this dream project.
They give you the
resources to do so,
and I just felt really excited
and proud of what we had made
and sad to see it go.
But also just very grateful
for the opportunity
to have made something with
such an extraordinary group
of people and with such
fantastic mentors behind us
and supporting us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]